good morning it is a pleasure for me to
welcome you Donald Tusk here today in
bont the record turnout in the elections
that took place in Poland on October
15th has shown once again that polls are
strongly attached to
democracy Donal Tusk and me we will be
discussing important issues today in
which the voice of Poland is crucial the
war at the borders of our Union and the
continued support for Ukraine will be
one of
them polls are proud
Europeans they have already shown
enormous
solidarity and took responsibility in
many
dimensions we will also talk about the
future of our European security
architecture and our discussions will
certainly be about modernizing our
economy as well as its future
competitiveness we want our European
companies to keep their leading position
in clean tech and in other modern
sectors of the economy we want growth
and new jobs to be created here in
Europe we want to deliver in the best
possible way for our
citizens we will talk about democracy in
Europe and all those values that are at
the heart of the European Union and
finally we will discuss the progress on
Next Generation EU in Europe and I know
that Donal Tusk and I will find a lot of
common ground on all these issues the
floor is yours
thank you madam president
deula dear
friends almost 10 years
ago in my first speech as a president of
the European Council I
said that I came to Brussels with a
strong sense of purpose and I think I
can repeat these words also
today this uh purpose today is to re the
position of my country in Europe and to
strengthen the EU as a
whole the results of the elections in in
Poland and the amazing turnout you said
it already also among the youngest
voters in in
Poland showed clearly to the whole of
Europe I think that democracy rule of
law freedom of speech European Unity are
still really important to our
citizens I am really proud of my
compatriots they have proved that the
anti-democratic and anti-european
mood doesn't have to be a
trend that it's just seasonal
turbulence I
hope I am so proud to be a
pole and to be a
European we all have proved to ourselves
but also to the world that if you
believe in change if you make an effort
it will pay off and it
did Thea polls waited for this moment
for so long for long eight years and
this is why if you allow me I I I would
like to
say some words in in
Polish
[Music]
PR
for
thank you very much thank you thanks L
let's go over there too thank
you